so as I walked in you guys are watching
football or is it both you're watching
the same time a football yeah Wales is
my rugby team and they're not playing at
the moment something yeah yeah we got a
family oh well yeah all right and so
what football team do you I'm a West Ham
supporter and we're playing right now
and we've just gone one nil up so it's
nice being in the States because
footballs on really early in the day so
I do it like a I do like a fantasy
football league I've never done it
before when I'm doing it this year for
the first time which makes you more
invested than ever yeah it's great right
it's great and you root and you do run a
rub it's the Six Nations is on at the
moment which is all the nations of the
UK and then France and Italy and it
happens once a year and they'll play
each other once it's a massive deal I
was like the Super Bowl but for European
rugby yeah and harder yeah right anyway
and you said you root for Scotland
got it are they doing well and they are
being beat at the moment by two points
right so yeah that can turn around in an
instant I was gonna say yeah these were
fast oh yeah yeah yeah exactly
um so jumping in first of all awesome I
like talking about sports and I just
know nothing about rugby and I know a
little but we're off on the tangent so
um
really great to see you guys again I now
have seen you more than some of my
friends yeah that's very cool how much
fun did you have rockin the Mohawk while
you were filming um I liked it I liked
it a lot it's a kind of look that it
subconsciously gives out a vibe which
says please don't approach me yeah and I
really liked it I liked it a life that I
think I had one mobile can my life
before this one did you actually when
you took it out for a spin like offset
yeah did you notice people treating you
differently yeah definitely definitely
I I did a thing a couple of years ago
where I'd have a grill mate and they let
me keep it afterwards so whenever I
travel through air pours I always put my
grill in and no one ever know you never
get you never get selected for random I
get branded a lot beef did you go out
with with the
real and the Mohawk yeah and oh nothing
just just left alone it's great right
you should pick some fight next time at
the bar yeah if anyone would [ __ ] with
you I'm gonna come and get some grills
now I'm in my safe there's some great
girls here right I watched the film
again
last night and I enjoyed it even more
and the thing that I took away from it
is just how well Steven balanced the
humor and the heart and it's loaded with
really funny jokes and the crowd just
ate it up can you sort of talk about how
Steven and that it's really funny but it
also as I was saying it balances that
humor in heart I think that's always the
case in in comedies I grew up watching
comedies I was obsessed with them and I
think when when the story then turns
like into a darker point or IR becomes
more touching I think that the fall is
always twice as hard if it's in a comedy
and I think it's almost twice as
effective III my my favorite comedies
are not just my favorite because they're
so funny but because they make you cry
and I think um particularly like stuff
that Stephens done before I think you
can see that running all the way through
it like it's all the way through the
office like the office as a whole it's a
it's a love story in the office
basically it's just got funny bits
either side and so I think he's think
he's a bit of a master of that yeah I
think immediately Stephen lives in the
dark place you know he dwells within the
darkness like a lot of us do and so can
comedy-wise I think it's a lot easier to
undercut something which potentially
could be too schmaltzy or too much hard
you know it's easy to undercut that with
comedy and it's it's a nice thing to do
because it makes you realize but you
know I think like most comedies that it
has to be funny because if it's just
small C and there's no comedy in it it's
it just becomes kind of you know I mean
it it's confusing to itself it's also
like I think conventional where what
you've seen that done before yeah yeah
so you guys write Sundance for the film
looking back on it now what was that
experience like because I saw nothing
but positive stuff about the movie
yeah I think this week particularly
after Sundance and things I've just kind
of been people really like it you know
and the rocks in it and it's like oh
this could be really big you know do
great you know yeah it's a nice feeling
yeah and in the room it was it was
amazing like and it's a very
specifically British sense of humor that
runs through it but all the Americans
got it yeah I don't know if it was all
Americans in that room but they did get
it at least five boys five America yes
exactly
um I've you what I call fun questions
okay nothing to do with the movie we'll
see if you can done well uh what TV show
would you both love to guest star on
Silicon Valley a the young offenders
okay do your favorite sci-fi or fantasy
film that's not called Paul element for
me oh my god yeah oh my god yeah I
landed with spaceship in those thing
okay uh do you have a favorite Supergirl
Buffy I'm a big big fan of the Batman
films Howard the Duck
what film scared you as a kid The Omen
I'm brought Catholic so I didn't realize
that was until I was 15 I had a big AI a
bad encounter with an episode of moss
which is I sort of running drama in this
III never watch skinny stop and Morse
was the sort of type of waiter got scary
yeah um is there anything that you
collect and
and let old tiny little figurines do I
build like little Christmas villages at
Christmas you get them in my garden
Santos it's really nice human fingers
that explains everything about you um do
you remember your first movie or TV show
crush oh okay so there was a lady oh oh
Jenny Agutter from like its immediate
yeah well because I still yeah Jenny
Agutter I remember watching like being a
young man and watching werewolf it
American well for London and then
there's the sex scene where she's a
nurse they stay with me forever
I'll never say that image and Raquel who
was Dell boy's wife
she's really classic maybe it was the
context I think she was filthy yeah you
had a real kind of yes pain 9905 yeah
yeah yeah real bad in the bed set came
home I have a million others but I'm out
of time okay
I will just say thank you for indulging
me Congrats on the movie sincerely I
hope it's a huge thanks thank you
[Music]